أطلقوا عليها اسم هيا
عندما وصلت تقطعت بهم السبل على
الشاطئ منا يا صاح ، فهذا يعني أنه على قيد الحياة كان
اسمًا وأمل أن
السلحفاة ضخمة الرأس التي يبلغ وزنها 80 كيلوغرامًا كانت تنزف من
رأسها ولم يعرف العاملون في
مركز إنقاذ السلاحف البحرية الإسرائيلية ماذا
نوع من الإصابات الداخلية لذلك كانت
كيا هي رابع سلحفاة في اليوم
تغسل على شواطئ إسرائيل وفي اليوم
الخمسين في أسبوعين آمل أن نتمكن
من علاجهم جميعًا
بأقصى سرعة ممكنة بأفضل طريقة ممكنة.
لا يمكننا أنه ليس من غير المألوف أن تقطع
العواصف القوية السلاحف البحرية على شواطئ
شرق البحر الأبيض المتوسط ، ال
مر غير المألوف هو الإصابات التي أصيبوا بها ال
ن من عشرات السلاحف التي تم العثور عليها في
لأسبوع الماضي ، وقد مات أكثر من 20 سلاحفًا با
فعل.  رقائق طازجة على غلافها
، ينزف الآخرون غالبًا ما يكون هناك
ضرر داخلي أيضًا ، ومن الصعب
معرفة سبب معاناتهم جميعًا من
صدمة الأنسجة الرخوة التي تأتي من
نوع ما من موجة الصدمة
التي يمكن أن تحدث من أي من النوبات.
استطلاعات الميكروفون أو المتفجرات تحت الماء إذا كانت
لأسباب عسكرية أو لصيد الأسماك ولكن
ليس من الشائع أن يطلق المركز على هذا ،
يتم إحضار السلاحف في وحدة العناية المركزة الخاصة
بهم هنا لإجراء الفحوصات والعلاجات الأولى ،
الخزانات هنا ممتلئة ،
الطاولات التي تم أخذها بالفعل في المركز
تحركت السلاحف للعثور عليها  مساحة لمزيد من
السلاحف ، فهي تفوق طاقتها
ولكنها لن تترك مجموعًا عالقًا في
غضون ستة أشهر ، ويأملون أن
تصبح السلاحف العالقة بصحة جيدة مرة أخرى
لتطلق في المحيط نوعًا من المرآة
لما نفعله ونحصل على
السلاحف بخطافات و  مع إصابات الشعار
والبلاستيك وأكياس الطعام
المتشابكة فيها وكلها بها
قمامة وقمنا برميها في البحر
قبل الانتهاء من علاج
كليو ، تلقى المركز مكالمة واحدة
تم العثور على سلحفاة أخرى عالقة بالفعل
أورانج ليبرمان سي إن إن  وسط اسرائيل